- God, this is going to be
the best night of my life!
Yes!
(beat boxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- Here's the thing,
now that I'm in charge--
- [Adam] Mm-hmm.
- Get on my coat tails.
You can't be messing
around at the office.
I look at it this way,
promotion, car, wife.
We're gonna change things
up around the office.
I'm gonna let Alice know
who's in charge now.
Let's keep things the same.
Oh my God, what is this?
That's what we
call diversifying.
Do you even know karate?
Two, three.
- No, repa.
- Get used to this.
- Boss.
(Anders burping)
(mimics pig squealing)
(group laughing)
(Anders cheers)
- I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Can a motherfucker
get the check please?
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- For life, yep.
(group cheering)
♪ Give me something real baby ♪
♪ I'ma give you
something real shorty ♪
♪ Now come here when
you're home alone ♪
♪ I'll be waiting by the
phone so I can pick up ♪
♪ And I could, and I could ♪
♪ And I could give you
something real baby ♪
♪ I'ma give you
something real shorty ♪
♪ Give it to you like I
should, make you feel so good ♪
♪ So when I get my hands
on you, I'ma I'ma ♪
♪ I'ma give you ♪
♪ Something real baby ♪
- Whoa, whoa Ben, been cool.
- Just keep a living.
(group cheering)
- Hmm-hmm.
(hip hop music)
- I love my life!
(groaning)
- God bless America.
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- Looking good but you
gotta wonder if his age
is gonna be a factor in
this year's Tour de Franzia.
(group yelling)
- I gotta slap the bag!
I needa slap the bag!
- [Adam] You can do it,
we all believe in you.
Very good.
- [Blake] Oh, he
lost his helmet!
- He missed the flamingo!
- Oh it's catching up to ya.
- Nice, yeah.
Aww.
- What is that?
That's not beer.
- No, it's whiskey.
I watered it down though.
- [Anders] Okay,
all right, fine.
- With beer, here we
go, come on, come on.
(Anders choking)
(Blake laughing)
Who's the best!
(Blake cheering)
Yeah!
(upbeat music)
- Come on Dersel Hasselhoff,
Baywatch those beers,
you're doing great!
- No, dude I can't do it,
I'm starting to get hot mouth.
- (grunts) Come on
they need your help.
Clock's ticking by Bob,
let's go!
- No, no.
(laughing)
(water splashing)
(Adam laughs)
Yeah, get 'em!
Oh!
- Oh, my gosh.
- That is foul.
- Nobody's puked in the pool
in like a while.
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- Let's get drunk!
- Yeah.
- (laughs) Now we're talking!
- All right.
(beer taps popping)
- One, two, three, chug race.
- [Group] Chug race, chug race!
♪ 'Cause you had a bad day ♪
- You chug it boy, chug it!
(Blake cheering)
- And that's the
figure-four baby!
- Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
(group humming)
(group laughing)
♪ And you go for a ride ♪
♪ You had a bad day,
the camera don't lie ♪
♪ You're coming back down,
and you really don't mind ♪
(Anders belching)
♪ You had a bad day ♪
(Blake and Adam laughing)
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- C'mon everybody
let's get a beat going
like our ancient ancestors.
(group cheering)
(tribal drum beating)
Let's go, get louder.
(group yelling)
(into tribal music)
(group cheering)
(group whistling)
(group chanting)
(golf club striking)
- [Blake] Fore!
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- Energy.
(slow electronic music)
(into uptempo electronic music)
♪ I'm in love with a,
I'm in love with a ♪
♪ I'm in love with a monster ♪
(bleeps)
(dubstep music)
- Oh, oh--
- All right.
- Oh, oh.
- Okay,
easy mounting.
- Magic Miking this!
(gibbering)
- Yeah,
that's a little rough, please.
- You guys feeling the energy?
- Everyone, aye, show
that baby some love.
Let's bump up on that baby bump.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, here we go.
Bump up on that baby bump.
You gotta bump up
on that baby bump.
- Bump up on that
baby bump, Adam.
(group chanting)
- On that baby bump.
You gotta bump that baby bump.
- Bump up on that baby bump.
- [Adam] On that baby bump.
You gotta--
- Montez where are you going?
Montez get back here!
Would you please
just get off of me--
- What are you doing?
- The music stopped.
- I'm not done dancing.
- The music stopped and
your dancing is a joke.
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- God, this is gonna be
the best night of my life!
Yes!
(hiphop music)
Oh my God!
♪ Came down ♪
♪ Tip-toeing in my Jordans ♪
♪ Just copped a Porsche ♪
(group yelling)
♪ Tip-toeing in my foreign ♪
♪ You mother borin ♪
♪ You sleeping on me, snorin ♪
- This is the best
day of my life.
♪ Tip-toeing in my Jordans ♪
♪ I done came down ♪
♪ Just copped a Porsche ♪
♪ Tip-toeing in my foreign ♪
♪ You mother boring ♪
- This is awesome.
It's been a dream of mine
since I heard about it
in the Penthouse letters.
- [Stripper] Yeah.
- My grandma used
to read them to me
so I could fall
asleep more easily.
(beatboxing music)
♪ I'm fresh ♪
- Do you guys wanna get some,
some more drinks?
Party a little bit?
- Yes!
- Yeah.
- Yes.
(girls laughing)
- And some dipping chocolates.
- [Adam] Woo!
♪ I think you're freaky
and I like you a lot ♪
(upbeat electronic music)
- No!
♪ I think you're freaky ♪
♪ And I like you a lot ♪
- Oh my God! (laughs)
I did that to a real girl!